hi how are you I'm good how we feel and
how we feeling what's going on oh I'm
doing okay we're here we're live
are you just a naturally positive person
comes it all happy listen man I'm living
life I'm enjoying it you only one he's
in a DC franchise yeah yeah look at he's
the best-looking human being I've ever
met not good I appreciate Reynolds and
then you in this room but let's be
honest a very low bar a giant thing to
feel great about it yeah because I was
watching I was watching huh
Justice League Monday and something in
our Start Wonder Woman obviously I've
seen all these movies but like for some
reason it just struck me when I was
watching Justice League like I have an
incredible crush on gal gadot hmm is it
is it intimidating to work with somebody
who's that good-looking no I mean she's
I feel like she's just as nice if not
nicer than she is good-looking scare me
well yeah I mean it's it's oh it's a
warmth you know and I think there's a
sort of magnetism but she you know when
she talks to you she she never makes you
feel intimidated in that way as far as
I'm as far as I've known everybody was
super welcoming on the production though
how is it to get because cyborg is an
important superhero in in Justice League
but you see you Aquaman revealing
Aquaman for the first time back looking
by the way I was gonna say lash but you
got you three flash cyborg in an Aquaman
this is your first appearance for DC
yeah and you're next to Batman the whole
and in the Superman
[Laughter]
but how was it were you intimidated
working with all these guys and and she
Wonder Woman and Batman already have
done movies together and everybody you
know the crazy thing is everybody was
super welcoming there there was this
sort of team camaraderie before we even
stepped on set you know back when they
were shooting Batman V Superman and I
was you know getting tests makeup on for
that for that scene you know the trailer
of the makeup trailer starts rocking
back and forth and I'm like what the
hell's going on it's an earthquake
and in pops Jason Momoa just bear hugs
like it's all love you know it was it
was such a strange thing because you
know we knew we'd be in it for the long
haul - can you explain the backstory of
your character sure cuz it isn't as
well-known as Aquaman and not know
cyborg was actually created in the 1980s
for a comic run called the New Teen
Titans and he's a college athlete who
has a tragic accident befall him and in
order to save his life his father uses
alien technology that basically saves
his life but turns him into a cyborg so
he has super strength super durability
he can he can access anything
technological he he can fly and it helps
me maintain and regulate his body
function what's his weakness his
weakness I mean there's no specific
weakness that he that is represented
with him right I think a lot of his
struggle is an internal one because
unlike the other superheroes
he can't take off the suit you know he's
cyborg 24/7 right yeah everybody else
can go live a normal life and just give
it up
yes know how to work all of it right you
said well he doesn't know how to work
all of it you know hours all the thing
his towers are new so it being alien
technologies I'm going to continue to
evolve he's figuring it out as he
absolutely as best he can so I was
reading that you gained a whole bunch of
muscle mass for this movie but then I
saw the movie and like your whole body
is CGI doubt cuz you're like a robot
yeah in the movie I was like why would
they make you gain all that muscle mass
if they're just gonna well there's some
sequences that we shot of a cyborg prior
to his accident and so to portray the
college quarterback you know and putting
on about 30 pounds so also with respect
to the costume itself yeah cuz I'm in a
onesie the entire time everybody else
has a practicum costume which weighs
about you know 3040 pounds and you know
for me having that extra weight made me
feel outside of my body so
it kind of put me in a different posture
so it actually helped with the
physicality of everything as well how
long did it take you to put the weight
on run a year and a half because my body
responds pretty quickly to what I do for
the positive or for the negative so you
know they were just shoving food steaks
chicken fish quinoa five meals a day
three big meals two small meals and in
the gym two hours a day working out so
they were if they were telling you what
you needed everything you know and diet
is maybe I would say 95% of anything
physical you do and so for me to get to
the maximum weight I was at about 193
when we started and I was 224 by the
time I was at my maximum with all muscle
I would hope so yeah what did you do
before you acted before I was acting I
think this is all I've been doing since
I was about 16
okay so life is where are you from I'm
from New Jersey alongside is the town
its nature South Jersey near Cherry Hill
South Jersey's the reason why they
called the Garden State right that's
[Laughter]
North Jersey for such a long time now
people are talking about the north south
jersey seceding from north jersey for
coming its own state look we've only
known you for about 10 minutes but I
would say that anybody listening would
guess that you come from a better area
of the world
[Laughter]
usually people are like oh you don't
sound like you from New Jersey and I was
like I'm not sure what that sounds like
but I guess when you get into acting
especially when you when you join this
franchise because this is like you said
like you're already signed on to do a
cyborg solo movie and to continue on
with the group movies do you have to go
to like accent training and drop the
kind of no for me I guess we're where we
come from in South Jersey there isn't a
sort of hard accent no Philly accent oh
yeah the Philly accent trickles over
like certain certain words like water
will say water moves out of water yeah
but like that's easy that's an easy fix
if you want to neutralize that accent
it's like being a newscaster you kind of
have to sound like you're writing
nowhere exactly nowhere and everywhere
you don't want anyone to say go yeah
this guy lives here or this guy's not
absolutely but so you did that you
didn't go to like accent class or
anything you steady yourself I went to
conservatory here in New York and with
conservatory conservatory is an
intensive program where you where you
study acting or whatever whatever
special specialized field you want to be
a part of that was a year and a half
program got out of there and just
started pounding the pavement trying to
get involved in theater in any way shape
or form
what are you parents do my mom's a nurse
my mom's on our end dad with dad was
never in the picture my mom's an RN and
I've got two brothers and two sisters
you know your dad now just never and
never in the picture right yeah so the
thing is until he sees you on Justice
League
billboards then he's gonna start that's
a whole different situation but you know
it what's what's great about the
characters because he had a very sorted
relationship with his father
yeah you know is able to sort of draw
from from personal experience when it
came to the crafting of all that so is
there is there a security in when you
get a role like this because it's such a
big thing right like it this is the
blockbuster role it's leading to a bunch
of different movies like it's such a big
thing is there security knowing that
this is going to continue on past one
movie or is there an intimidation factor
of being like I had to live up to
not at all no security whatsoever I feel
like as an actor you know you you you
dedicate your life to uncertainty you
know and hopefully these movies continue
hopefully it's well received and it
makes tons of money and you know people
want to see more of it but you don't
want to you don't want to rest on your
laurels
you definitely don't want to count on it
happening because things change they
swap people out and superhero movies -
it's the 19 Batman's Michael because
they have a in the TV show they already
have somebody playing cyborg in the
cartoons oh the defenders am I correct
I'm the biggest comic book fan I know
everything comma B what are you talking
about
baby baby maybe I'm from I'm a Marvel
fan first time in a you know one of the
in this DC movie universe and Ray had to
subtly say that he was in Batman yeah
that's my be super very nice movie just
like it was like a 10 second right I'm
gonna help you you don't know please New
Teen Titans I had the number 1 I
collected comic books when I was a kid
Titans he actually came to premiere in
LA and I get out I haven't haven't been
starstruck in quite a long time but
being able to sit down and chat with
Marvin was pretty intense did you
collect comics in your kid I didn't know
my mom really got us comics but I was a
big fan of the animated series and a big
fan of the movie series of everything
I'd watch everything it didn't matter
Disney Marvel didn't matter is it hard
acting
memorize your lines they tell them to
with all the CGI because it's not a
regular scene with another act of some
of this stuff the people aren't even
there you're looking at something
looking at tennis balls on sticks you
know you looking at people wearing
onesies with you know huge poles on top
and pretending it's a 12 foot tall
monster McWhite skillset I really do but
coming from theater a lot of times you
just imagine and stuffs there that's not
there anyway so you do a play in a block
black box theater and there's no set
there's no nothing there's no costumes
in that same zone what's what's the
first play did first play I ever did was
into the woods in high school
[Laughter]
vos has to imagine crowds are there when
he does he's had a hard time on the road
[Laughter]
so I'll play the narrator one of the
narrator's and I played the wolf which
was pretty dope I know what the play is
about the play it's basically Stephen
Sondheim took all of Grimm's fairy tales
and sort of combined it into a into a
sort of New Age imagining and it's about
it's about the choices that people make
and how fairytales don't always end up
being fairytale endings does he do
musicals see this one yeah yeah so was
that a musical yeah oh I used to I don't
sing as much as I used to but that's how
I got involved in it all yeah but you
can sing I mean I can all the tunes
just my voice a little bit please Thanks
Irish do the--can itís a lot of
comedians can't say rich is embarrassed
because you did a good job in karaoke
before that's enough now I say your
third movie he's doing it again movie
you'll probably have enough power to
maybe throw somebody in that you want
maybe some
when your this is you can ignore yeah
when you say Zack Snyder obviously it
leaves a film because of pretty severe
personal reasons like they said it was
like four fifths of the way done more or
less you know whatever was it difficult
to then jump over to a different
director because it was Joss Whedon
I mean I think it was difficult just in
general I mean you you step on the set
with Zack he treats everybody with so
much dignity you know it would have
regardless of what job you're doing you
know you could be the janitor cleaning
up and he'll treat you with the same
respect as he treat Ben Affleck or
anybody else you know he's just that
kind of guy
so losing him on the production was
tough and obviously you got a handle the
situation with respect to your family
that comes first
but you know we sort of banded together
and it was sort of like let's do it for
Zack yeah so I feel like that sort of
carries carries us through who's your
favorite character off set when you do
like hanging around between scenes
myself and Jason clicked in a really big
way known each other for many many years
but we're all the newer guys ax and
Jason you know he's really good at
getting people out getting people to
come out and hang out have a drink at
the bar that kind of thing yeah and you
know it was super super oh I catch it at
a dartboard
exactly exactly feel good when you
realize because you are gonna be for
better or worse
hopefully stuck with these people for a
few movies franchise so when you get
there and you realize that like there is
this thing where they want to have a
pleasant experience because I'm sure
there are people who have been stuck
with actors on films that they don't
like sure there's certainly people stuck
on the radio the crazy thing is I you
know you you know when to give people
their space and we know when it's time
to work it's time to work and you try to
have as much fun as you can in between
takes because there's I mean honestly I
mean you guys were seeing there's a lot
of downtime there's an extreme amount of
downtime but I feel like everybody
because our personalities are so
different there
nobody really clashes in that way and if
you need some space you go off and you
know hang on you're sorry I was gonna
ask if you're worried at all that cuz
gal gadot has said she doesn't want to
come back to be Wonder Woman unless I'm
not attached you want some completely
unattached when you read something like
that are you like oh my god like you
know worst case scenario I do not want
to do these movies anymore with that gal
gadot as Wonder Woman like this well no
I think it's on everybody to make the
decision for themselves whatever feels
whatever feels right I mean that if it's
if that's a conviction that's your
conviction go with it yeah I'm I'm not
gonna knock it I'm not I mean that's
that's it you got every right to do what
you believe what these don't leave to
his wife Westar
what is fetch clay make man about fetch
clay make man is a play written by
willpower about the relationship between
Muhammad Ali the late great Muhammad Ali
and step-in Fetchit who was a
vaudevillian
vaudevillian actor yeah and was seen by
some as a sort of pariah sellout or do
they seem as old and they saw him doing
a sort of sellout caricature I think
that's sort of how history had
remembered him at the time but
apparently Muhammad Ali instead of
Fetchit knew one another in real life
and we're actually really good friends
you know and it was it seemed odd that
Ali who was you know Pro black in the
60s and sceptre Fetchit who was seen as
that pariah you know became friends so
the play is about this you know this
chance meeting right
you remember that Sonny Liston fight the
second fight the Phantom punch yeah well
yeah yeah so loss was their willpower
apparently Ali what he was quoted as
saying that step-in Fetchit had taught
him that punch right which you know Ali
he was some of the things he was saying
you know we're sort of outlandish and
sure but other things you know you
didn't know whether or not he was being
truthful or whether or not he was just
putting that Ali sauce on it and so I
will power was like well what if
stepping effect should actually really
did teach him that punch that and and
what would that look like what would
that meeting look like and so it's this
sort of fictitious meeting between Ali
and stuff and fetch it where Ali's
trying to get stuff and fetch it to
teach him the the anchor punch the fan
punch that he claims step-in Fetchit
learned from Jack Johnson the first
black heavyweight champ of the world so
it yeah so it's a fictional meeting
between two people who actually really
knew each other absolutely and you play
dolly I play dolly in that yeah and what
kind of pressure is that because he's
such a recognizable person that you do
you're playing guy who everybody knows
what he supposed to look like it's what
he supposed to sound like yeah
in the original run of the play I was
playing a non-speaking ensemble member I
was a really skinny kid really green and
Ben Vereen was playing step-in Fetchit
at that point in time and you know when
I stepped into the into that play I told
him I said listen if this ever moves to
New York like I want to understudy Ollie
and he's like listen man if you started
working on it now you could play out Lee
and I was like well let me get working
on it and that's when I started eating
everything and get my hands on you know
following where the production was at
you know fiending lusting after this
thing for about three years for a play
that was going off Broadway which is
kind of unheard of right you spend a lot
of time sure in that way and it ended up
working out in a really really big way I
had a lot of lead up time to get really
acclimated to who-who I believed I'll
lead to be and just getting my
interpretation of it down so by the time
we actually stepped onto the scene like
I felt super comfortable you know you
had to voice down I hear it let me let
me see with the note I don't wrestle
with an alligator
I don't tussle with a whale I don't
handcuff lightning through thunder in
jail well just today I murdered a rock
injured a stoned hospitalized a brick
I'm so mean I make medicine sick I'm bad
I see other character dum dee
well yeah that's uh did you ever beat
him do you ever get mean I did not get a
chance to meet him unfortunately no and
we were shooting Justice League at the
time when he when he passed away last
year and they had this this great
exhibit at the o2 Center out there and
it was it was it was really special to
see you know you got to see a lot of the
memorabilia from it from his like home
like they had the like some of the
molding from like the door of his
childhood yeah and just to be able to
see and be in the presence of like these
these sort of like humbling articles of
history you know was like it brings him
into a real sort of real perspective you
know view Joe Frazier one time when he
was promoting that uh the documentary he
did about the thriller and no I think
and you realize that Ali what it was as
much as he was loved there was an
another side to Ali to where he could be
a little vindictive and all he was a
human being and he had he as a complete
guy and when you listen to Frazier talk
you kind of felt bad for for Frazier a
little bit to this [ __ ] that he had to
take yeah absolutely
I mean and that's the crazy thing I
think about Ali was that he is
transformed so many times over the
course of his life you know if there's
anything he serves the power of
transformation you know and and you know
I think by the time he reached getting
toward the end of his life you know he
sort of reached this place of being
universally beloved but you know when he
first started out people wanted him like
dead you know when he was part of the
Nation of Islam and growing up and when
he converted to change his name from
Malcolm I'm sorry from Cassius Clay to
Cash's X then Cash's ex to Muhammad Ali
like he was a very he was a figure of
controversy I mean going through Vietnam
and all that you know but I think Angley
one of his next projects is a 3d boxing
movie about Muhammad Ali and Joe Frazier
and their rivalry and I think they touch
upon that that aspect a little bit you
know just looking at it from both sides
because 3d movie 3d boxing movie yeah
it's just like this box at this crazy
technology that he wants to use to to
really to really immerse you in the
boxing match any I would imagine the
fight scenes you're gonna be like
incredible I would hope so yeah and
that's actually how I ended up getting
you know a little bit to this point he
had actually come and saw and saw that
play you know for three years ago now
three and a half four years ago and that
ended up creating a lot of hype and
that's how I got my first agent manager
and you know ended up taking the trip
out to LA and meeting the folks and
Warner Brothers and getting involved
with the the Justice League of saw so do
you want to play Ollie in the movie I
mean
if it comes around and everything works
out yeah I mean that'd be a great thing
to do
I would love to down the mantle but what
type of time commitment is the is the
Justice League stuff though cuz I gotta
see that movie is shot and done and it's
out on Friday yeah but like in terms of
carrying on the cyborg character does
that mean ever most things have to be
put on hold for a few years
no I mean we're not going to shoot the
next thing I don't think into it I mean
it's not even on the docket yet
everything is sort of still in the
production phase the pre-production
phase so I mean these things will come
out and then they'll be gone you know
but you're able to find pockets of time
see to slip projects in my thing is
though like I want to do things that I'm
actually passionate about you know
things that actually care about I don't
want to just do I don't want to work for
the sake of working because then you end
up just sort of watering down but it is
your love and for me I'm like love my
time and I got too little time on this
earth and my your gift is too precious
to go ahead and just go alright let me
just do it for the sake of doing it you
know see that's a very positive attitude
we should all incorporate a positive
attitude you know this is a big
superhero movie moment could come where
you're like you know what I also want to
eat in New York you know and in
conservatory there are a lot of days
where I was broke had to move back into
my mom's house multiple times back to
New Jersey tell her hey listen mom you
still got that basement okay that's uh
no I said last time would be the last
time but here well now and you know I've
been on the grind in a really big way
you know coming out here
my buddy Jaron who you know went to
school with still a really good friend
of mine it got to the point where it's
like look I've got peanut butter you've
got bread let's make some sandwiches you
know I mean like that kind of feel
so know what I mean I know what that
that life is like but even then even at
the lowest of the low I still felt this
sort of sense of calm about the
situation because I'm like you know what
it's about the small victories like even
doing like the off off off off off
Broadway things like it was something
that I wanted to do it was passionate
about I was willing to make the
sacrifice yeah is it hard to go from the
transition from instant gratification of
being on stage to movies where you know
it's not laughing at you you are I am
not laughing yet yes you are Bocchetti
I'm laughing at my friends laughing at
the fact that you said I know where
you're going with this that's his nice
way of going shut up nice person he's
not a terrible question no I mean there
is a certain level of there's a certain
level of not knowing because we're
theatre you get that ugly applause in
the same day it's like it's like
stand-up comedy I mean you know like the
energy of the audience informs the
performance and you know you get it then
you walk away and do the show again the
next day with this it's so much waiting
you're just like alright well we did
that perfect we did the performance we
did the take and now it's in the hands
of the editor and the post-production
people to ultimately make it look like
what ready hope it looks like stop
taking pride in the fact that he could
answer your question when you didn't
even get to finish asking you was there
any part of this movie that was
dangerous you almost get hurt
filming it not for the most part no they
do wet the sets down a lot just to get
some like reflective surfaces and that
was you one thing in movies that I
learned is that you see the streets and
they and they're always looking to just
rained out yeah yeah and I was like oh
[ __ ] that's for life that's for light
and they bounce it they bounce it off
and these are things I didn't even know
like if you don't have a wet treat it
just looks yeah I mean I didn't know
honestly all those technical aspects I'm
like I'm like a kid in the candy store
I'm like oh what's this - what's that
Duke why are they doing that with the
with these like metallic balls why are
they like spraying down the street with
water and everybody was super
knowledgeable and just willing to go
ahead and give me the information they
give you any
did they give you the suit did they give
you anything friend I was up from the
suit not endeavors just pajamas I was
ready to leave that behind
yeah give you anything I got something
cool I don't know if Ash's I don't know
if I should say on radio really they may
not know I have it the wrong one the two
of you claim to know comics I never
should I know John I don't know anything
at what point in time the handling I've
actually seen the film you are in that's
great
The Hulk is great